TODD PRIVES: Hey, everyone.
I'm Todd Prives.
I'm a product manager on
Google Cloud Platform.
And I've spent my
entire 13-year career
working in visual
effects software.
I've always been
driven by the desire
to make tools to make
people's work better.
I've never quite considered
myself to be an artist.
So what drives me is helping
other people succeed.
And the fact that I've been
able to join Google Cloud
Platform through the
acquisition of Zync in September
is really exciting.
That Google is so
invested in this space,
and now to be able to be
standing here in front of you,
seeing all these people,
a lot of whom I've
worked with and known
for many, many years,
talking about the solutions
we're working towards
to make your lives better, to
make your work more efficient,
and to really improve what you
do, is really exciting to me.
And I'm just really happy
to be here as part of Google
right now.
So as [? Belle ?]
touched on before,
Google Cloud Platform is an
incredible infrastructure.
And it was really new for me
as well when I joined Google,
to understand what we're capable
of, what the scalability is,
and what you can achieve.
And the way I like
to describe it
is, it's the same infrastructure
that powers Google today.
So it's the same
infrastructure that
handles billions of search
queries on a daily basis.
It's the same
infrastructure that's
protected by over 500
security professionals whose
whole goal is to prevent
nation-state-sponsored attacks
from Google.
When we air the interview
on Christmas Day,
you can imagine the concerns
about what sort of hacking
might go on.
This is Google's bread and
butter, securing your data,
protecting your data.
And it's the same
infrastructure that
handles countless hours
of video every day
that are uploaded, transcoded,
and distributed worldwide
to hundreds of millions
of people via YouTube.
So to be able to offer
rendering solutions on top
of this infrastructure
is really exciting.
And I'm going to
talk about what I
believe as the scalability
and the visions
you can achieve from this.
And certainly as
[? Belle ?] addressed
before, rendering is only one
of the workloads we're tackling.
And we're doing this by
working with our own technology
as well as collaborating
with best of breed.
One of the things that when I
joined Google wanted to make
very clear is that we are not
going for a one-size-fits-all
solution.
In the media space, every studio
has a different way of working,
has a different pipeline,
has different tools
that they're used
to working with.
So we've spent a
lot of time not only
working on our own
internal technology
but really outreaching to
the best-of-breed technology
providers out there.
And you'll see some of them
speaking later on today
as to how they've been able to
bring their solutions to Google
Cloud Platform to
allow us to achieve
more and more offerings.
As a rendering
platform in particular,
there are some amazing things
that we can do with Google,
such as the permanent billing.
Again, [? as Belle ?]
was mentioning,
you're only paying
for what you use.
There's no 60-minute blocks.
There's no building
out of infrastructure
when you don't need it.
So especially for
burst capacity,
it's a fantastic tool.
And along those lines, it's
also designed to save you
money the more hours you run.
So we have this thing called
sustained use discounts.
Again, it doesn't require
any sort of pre-purchase
of allocated compute hours.
Literally, the more you run
a machine during the month,
the less you pay.
It just naturally gets cheaper.
And that's how we feel
it should be at Google.
Huge capacity.
You'll hear from Rodeo FX.
You'll hear from
Atomic Fiction how
they've been able to
scale to tens of thousands
of cores literally at the
press a button without having
to reserve these, with having
them available and just
paying for what you use.
And you can spin these
up very, very quickly.
As you'll see in a Zync demo
I'll give it a little bit,
I'm able to spin up 60 nodes
in a matter of minutes,
get the job up and running, and
finish the job, spin it down
when it's done.
And then specific to
some of the rendering
challenges we're tackling,
we have our turnkey solution,
Zync Render, which I'll
show you at the end, as well
as these technology
collaborations.
So I really can't
emphasize how important
it is for us to
build that ecosystem
working with companies
like Thinkbox,
with Avere, with Atomic
Fiction and their Conductor IO
rendering solution to
give you as many options
as you need to most
seamlessly and securely
migrate your existing pipeline
from an on-premise workload
to Google Cloud Platform.
So looking at
rendering workloads,
whether you're doing an NFS
mount on a nearby data center
or doing an asset sync
to a remote data center,
there are a lot of
the same challenges,
a lot of the same things
you have to build.
But what I really look at it
as is a hierarchy of needs.
From the bottom up,
at the baseline,
you have to make sure you can
get your assets to the cloud.
And you also want to
be smart about it.
You don't want to mirror
your entire file system.
You want to be able to parse a
scene for all its dependencies.
You want to make sure
you're only ever pushing up
the assets that are needed.
You want to make sure
you have enough licenses.
So you need the value--
if you're spinning up
1,000 machines, you want to
make sure you can spin up
1,000 concurrent licenses as
well and only pay for those.
And at the top of
this pyramid, I really
see pipeline integration.
So yeah, I can get
all the data up there,
I can intelligently parse a
scene, I can get licenses.
But what we're really striving
for with our solutions
on Google Cloud
Platform is something
that I keep saying fits
within your workflow,
makes it feel seamless.
So to the artists
or the TD, there's
no going outside of the way
they would normally work.
There are no extra steps.
And it just feels
exactly like it's part
of your local infrastructure.
The way I envision cloud
rendering essentially
is that you could have
10,000 machines running
on Google Cloud Platform
at a data center,
but it should feel like it's
in the room next door to you
in terms of the responsiveness,
in terms of the interactivity,
and in terms of the integration.
So one of the interesting
things that I've come across
in talking to a lot
of studios and getting
their feedback as to
how they view rendering
is the total cost of ownership.
And for a lot of studios, it's
simply along the lines of,
well, yes, I've invested
this much in a render farm.
These are my capital expenses.
And these are my ongoing
operating expenses
for like HVAC, licenses, power.
What I think we can do
with Google Cloud Platform,
and we think we've
seen done with quite
a few of our customers
so far, is also
cut down on the render times,
give you burst capacity
to the fact where the unknown,
unmonitored cost of idle artist
time, which a lot of studios
don't take into account,
is now really severely impacted.
So traditionally, you're
at a visual effects studio,
you have somewhat of a limited
capacity for a render farm.
So at some point, you're paying
a CG artist whatever you're
paying them to sit around and
wait for renders to come back
while they're in the queue.
So what we can do with
Google Cloud Platform
is achieve that scalability
where that added cost
that maybe you're not
factoring into what
the daily operational
expenses of a render farm are,
we actually are
mitigating those.
And you're not having artists
sitting around anymore waiting
for renders to come back.
But there's some amazing
parallel processing,
or jobs are coming back to
you really, really quickly,
and the artist efficiency,
which might be 20% or 30%
or 40% wasted time, is
really maximized so they're
able to work all the time.
As I was mentioning
before, we're
collaborating with what we
feel are the leading partners,
the leading technology providers
in the visual effects animation
software industry.
With Zync Render, we
are providing licenses
from Chaos Group, The
Foundry, and Solid Angle.
But as I also mentioned
before, we realize Zync is not
a one-size-fits-all solution.
It's great for small
to medium shops.
But we want to make
sure we can work across
as many pipelines
as possible, handle
as many workloads as possible.
So from that, we are really
excited to be working again
with very industry-leading
companies such as Avere,
and their virtual filer is
now available on Google Cloud
Platform.
Atomic Fiction,
which for a long time
was actually a
Zync customer, has
built their own
fantastic cloud rendering
platform called Conductor
IO on Google Cloud Platform.
And you'll hear about them
as well later on today.
And Thinbox Software, probably
the leading render manager
with their Deadline
solution, has also now
seamlessly extended
their platform
onto Google Cloud Platform.
And you'll be hearing
from them as well.
So just to reiterate,
the way I see
this is it's all about all the
technology collaborations we
can do and how we can bring all
these people to Google Cloud
Platform to migrate
your workload.
Avere in particular I want
to call out, as we just
announced this at NAB.
And this is really
designed for large studios.
Studios that are using Avere
locally to cache their data
can now seamlessly
migrate and sync that
to Google Cloud Platform.
So going back the idea of a
hybrid environment, if you have
studios in multiple locations
with multiple Averes,
all of that now
can be seamlessly
passed back and forth.
And we are focused on bringing
this hybrid environment
to studios.
We understand large studios have
a lot of on-premise hardware
they've invested in over time.
But rather than buy
more hardware or rent
hardware for burst capacity,
you can now literally
extend at the push of a button
to tens of thousands of cores
and sync all of your hot
data from your local Avere
caches to our Google Cloud
Platform Avere cache,
which is really,
really exciting.
And you'll be hearing
from them as well.
Some of the early customer
successes we've had, again,
Atomic Fiction, a pioneer
in visual effects rendering
on the cloud.
They've been doing
it for a while.
They'll tell you about
some of the great things
they're working on.
Rodeo Effects, you'll be hearing
from Jordan Soles, their CTO
and executive producer,
later on today
about how they've been able
to integrate Google Cloud
Platform and burst.
Industriromantik,
a smaller studio
you might not know
about, they're in Sweden,
an architectural design
visualization firm.
But again, being able
to seamlessly integrate
their pipeline into
Google Cloud Platform,
showing the breadth
of solutions we're
able to offer from small studios
all the way up to the really
large ones such
as Framestore, who
did a blog post in the fall
about how they were able to use
Google Cloud Platform to burst
to 15,000 cores for a very
short time.
So the alternative
is literally for them
spending $300,000
on new hardware
for this very short burst
capacity, which really
doesn't make a lot of financial
sense and is a lot of work
to get up and running.
And with Google Cloud
Platform, they're
actually able to build
their VM image within a day,
get it up and running, deploy
it, and start rendering tests
the next day.
I do want to take a
little bit of time
to talk to you about
Zync specifically.
It's very near and dear to
me, and it's a part of Google.
So I wanted to spend a
little bit more time talking
about Google's own cloud
rendering solution in addition
to all of these great technology
collaborations we have.
So Zync itself is built from
the ground up as a cloud
rendering solution.
It started in 2010 at a
very small visual effects
studio called Zero
Visual Effects in Boston.
The founder came from a long
career at Digital Domain,
I think actually worked
across the street, if not
in one of these buildings,
for about 10 years,
and wanted to build an
artist-friendly solution,
something that obfuscated
cloud, so for the artists
they didn't have to worry about
setting up filers or getting
licenses or command line
syncing any of their assets,
but literally a
front-end UI that would
be easy to use and fit into
their existing pipeline.
So the origins of Zync
and the genesis of Zync
has always been from a
professional visual effects
background.
We like to say it's by
artists for artists.
We understand how people work.
We understand how
they want to work.
And we have done our best
to integrate our solution
into that existing
pipeline to make it
as easy as possible to
use cloud, going back
to the idea of having a local
render farm in your back which
is actually thousands of
miles away in a data center.
Had a lot of great success
with feature films that
have been rendered on Zync.
Beyond that, we're looking
at small to medium studios,
over 12 million core hours in
total, hundreds of commercials.
In fact, Moonbot Studios
in Shreveport, Louisiana,
just won two Emmys for
their short film "Silent."
It was done for
Adobe Labs last year.
They rendered the entire thing
on Zync about nine months ago.
A classic example
of a small studio
that had a lot of
creative talent,
didn't necessarily want to
go out and spend the money
or could afford to spend
the money on a large render
farm for this for 4K
project-- it was the first 4K
project they've been given
for this three-minute short
animated film-- but were really
able to focus on the creative
by using Zync as an
integrated solution that
fit within their pipeline,
let the artists do their work
and submit the renders
from Maya as they needed.
Our workflow, and I'll
show you in a moment,
is really all focused
about intelligent asset
management and file management.
I think in our
industry we all realize
we create a lot of data.
We're moving a lot of data
between different locations.
And it's no
different with cloud.
You have to push data
up at some point.
So the way we've designed
Zync is to actually analyze
a scene for all of the assets,
all of the dependencies,
and upload those ahead of
time in the background.
So being able to
manage your pipeline,
being smart about
pushing all of the assets
up to the cloud
so they're there,
and at render time itself
when you go to submit a job,
the only thing that's going
to go up is a scene file.
We also keep a copy
of anything you
render on Zync on the cloud.
So if you're pushing
those CG renders into comp
and you're compositing in NUKE--
and again, I'll show you this--
and then you go ahead
and launch a NUKE job,
there's no file I/O to be done.
Everything has been
rendered on the cloud.
It stays on the cloud.
So we've tried to
design a system that
minimizes the
bottlenecks of file I/O
as it stands in our industry.
And I think we've done a
pretty good job with it.
So with that, I'm
going to actually take
a few minutes to just give
you a walkthrough of Zync here
running on Google
Cloud Platform and show
you the reality of things.
So Zync is now in a beta phase.
And I've got a Maya scene here.
So all you have seen Maya.
So this is just a
60-frame sequence here.
This police car actually has
about 500 different textures.
There's HDR material.
There's dependencies.
So there are a lot
of assets to manage.
And as I mentioned at
the beginning of my talk,
you don't want to mirror
your entire file system.
You want to be
intelligent about actually
parsing only the data you need.
So what we're able
to do with Zync
is actually parse a scene
file for all of that data
and upload it ahead of time.
So I want to go ahead and
launch the Zync plugin
from the Zync Shelf in Maya.
So we have a plugin
inside of Maya.
And once I launch this, you can
actually see our dialog box.
So the way we manage file I/O
is to run this upload-only job.
So when I click on this,
everything is grayed out.
I would go ahead and put
my username and password in
and submit the job.
So at that point, Zync is going
to do a scene analysis, again,
pull all my dependencies,
all of my assets
and upload those
in the background.
So by the time it actually
comes to render a job,
everything is up there.
So I've already done this.
So for the purposes
of the demo, I just
want to really quickly
run a job and walk you
through the user interface
and what the workflow is like.
So you can see here, I've
got the number of machines
I can choose to render.
And these are the Google
Cloud Platform machines.
So you don't have to go out
and build any sort of VMs.
You don't have to configure
any sort of command line render
management.
And this is a 60-frame
sequence, so Zync
has analyzed all of the data
necessary for a Maya scene.
It's a 60-frame sequence, so I
just want to use 60 machines.
This idea burst
ability, of scalability,
of being able to
turn jobs around
faster so your artists are
not sitting around idle at all
is something that's really
important to us and something
we're working very
hard to deliver.
So machine types, I've got
several different machine
types.
And these are based on the
standard Google Cloud Platform
machines.
I'm going to use the
32-core machines.
And you can see that's
priced at $2.08 an hour.
My total cost is $124.80.
But that's for the hour,
and we bill by the minute.
So if you were to
render this and it's
taking 11 minutes
in total, you'd
only pay that percentage
of the entire estimated
cost for the hour.
So I think having
permanent billing
is really critical in
the rendering workspace.
You're not wasting any time.
I'll go ahead and
set my project.
It's already synced.
I'll parse my Maya scene for my
output directory for my project
folder.
It knows I'm using V-Ray.
So for the renders, we support
V-Ray and Arnold right now.
For V-Ray, we support nightlies
and distributed rendering.
I'll just set the
chunk size to 1,
so I'll have every machine
working on a frame.
It's going to give me all
the different camera options.
I'll choose my beauty layer and
put in my username and password
and submit the job.
So Zync is then going to
go through, do a pass,
analyze the scene,
and actually upload
the scene to Google Cloud
Platform and start rendering.
So we'll just give
this a minute here.
It's going to go through
everything here, generate
that output pass, and upload it.
And so imagine you
have an artist now,
and they have 20
shots to work on,
and you have a render
queue that's backed up.
You'd essentially be
waiting for the one shot
at a time to just submit them.
But if you have an artist
who's got 20 shots lined up
and you're using Google Cloud
Platform and you're using Zync,
you can just submit those
jobs one after another.
There is no queue.
Just do one machine
in parallel per frame.
So the job has been
submitted to Zync.
I can go ahead and move
to my Web Render Manager.
So this is something we
built from the ground up.
It looks like many of the
render queue managers out there.
Again, we've tried to
design this with the idea
that people are using
existing software tools.
They want something that
fits in their pipeline.
They want something
that's easily integrated.
And in a few minutes, the
job is going to start up
and we'll see all
60 of those VMs
on Google Cloud Platform
with V-Ray licenses
spinning up and
rendering the job.
I think one other
important thing to note
is that this is not only
a GUI-based application,
but we also have full
Python scripting.
All of our plugins
are open source.
They're available on GitHub.
So we've had studios--
in fact, some of whom
are here-- who have done their
own command line scripting
if it's integrated into their
asset management system,
into their render manager to do
more advanced types of render
control management.
So we're trying to accommodate
as many different workflows
as possible and as many
different pipelines as possible
within Zync.
Again, going from the fact that
we come from a visual effects
background, we understand
how artists work.
So this job is now
spinning up here.
In a minute, we'll start
to see all of my machines.
But you can see I've got all
of my frames queued up here.
I'll see all 60 frames.
They're all queued
up ready to go.
You can see my output directory,
my frame range, my render
output.
So this is essentially
my output directory here.
This is my beauty pass.
So this is empty right now.
But as this job finishes,
those EXR frames
are going to come
back one at a time.
So you're not waiting for
an entire job to finish.
You're only waiting as long as
it takes for each chunk to go.
And in this case, I've
set the chunk to 1.
So very quickly, we'll start
to see those frames spin up,
render, and come right back down
to my local output directory.
So as an artist, you don't
have to think about anything.
You submit the job.
The job renders.
It comes right back down
to where you expected.
There's no fetching of files.
And it's designed as a
seamless integration.
So we've got all these
machines now spinning up.
You can see, I spoke at
the beginning about VMs
spinning up very, very quickly
on Google Cloud Platform.
This is no exception.
I've already got 34 of the
60 machines I requested up
and running in a
matter of minutes.
So we'll soon see all 60 of
those machines come online.
We'll see everything rendering.
And we'll see the final output.
So while this actually starts
up, there are a few more things
I want to show you
behind the scenes
that we built within Zync to
give you pipeline integration.
So I have a Maya
account page here.
And from this, this is all
the administrative stuff,
all of the custom scripts,
all of the shaders, anything
you would want to add
within this workflow
is available through Zync.
So we have the Admin Account
tab at the beginning.
And this where you
can set your username,
your password, your email.
If you're a non-admin, this
is the only thing you'll see.
So if you're just an
artist using the system,
this is the only
access you'll have.
But then we've also got
some advanced configuration
controls.
So you can configure things like
the max number of running jobs,
your custom gizmos for NUKE.
If you have custom shaders for
Maya, we support all of that.
Drive mapping-- so let's
say not all of your assets
are living on a single
NFS, you have assets living
on different machines,
you're able to set up
drive mapping to make sure you
can access all of those assets.
You're also able to
monitor your usage
on a monthly, daily, or weekly
basis, by host application,
by job.
So all of the billing you get
it done through the Google Cloud
Platform billing console.
And you actually get a
breakdown for every job ID
and how much you spent on every
One.
So I could say, yes,
I've rendered 45 hours
of the 16-core V-Ray
for this job for Nissan,
or 300 hours at $2.00 an hour
of Arnold for this job for Nike.
So it's very intuitive
in terms of being
able to take those
spends on rendering
and actually quantify
to the client,
yes, this is how
much it costs you.
These are the
iterations you want.
This is actually how much you
paid for it down to the minute.
And I should note that
all of our billing
is done totally inclusive.
So as I showed you
back in the Maya plugin
here, when I launched
a job, this price
you can see on the
32-core is $2.08 an hour.
That's inclusive
for V-Ray as well.
That's not a separate
breakout of compute,
then you have to pay for Zync
infrastructure or anything
like that, or V-Ray.
It's all bundled, trying to make
this as easy and as friendly
as possible.
A few more tabs here.
You can add users, projects.
So all of the data you render
on Zync is stored on Zync.
And I'll show you a nice
example of that in a moment.
But you also have full
access to all of your data.
You can delete that any time.
Typically, data
storage is cheap.
You're not paying
much on your bill.
It's $0.20 a gig a month, and
that ends up being maybe 5%
of a user's bill versus
the total compute.
But you're able to
see all of the usage
on a per-project basis.
And you can delete
that any time.
So typically, after
a job is done,
and perhaps you want to archive
it off to our nearline storage
or you're doing LTO, you're
able to go ahead and delete
those projects
whenever you want.
And one last thing
to mention is,
we've mirrored the entire file
structure of the files that
have been uploaded from
your local environment
onto Google Cloud Platform.
So if I were to look
at my demo project
here, just very quickly, you can
see I've got all of my scenes,
all of my source
images, all of the data
that goes into making
this Maya scene.
So when I go up to the cloud,
to Google Cloud Platform,
and I'm looking at the storage
we built for you of a filer
on top of Google Cloud
Platform, I can go through here
and I can actually see a mirror
of what my local directory
structure is.
So everything is meant to
be as intuitive as possible,
as simplistic as possible.
So I can go back
into my demo folder,
I can see all my Maya scenes,
I can see all the assets,
and I'll be able to actually
parse all of the data.
So you can see scenes,
images, source images.
So you're able to actually
see all of the data that's
needed for the render that's
been uploaded to Google Cloud
Platform, to Zync.
So when I go back to
my main page here,
we've actually got the
job up and running.
And you can already see
the first few frames are
going to be done in a moment.
So this first frame is at 99%.
And it'll go from rendering
to downloading to done.
And I'm just going to leave
my file directory open,
so you'll see those EXR
frames come in one at a time.
But within this, we've
also done the same thing
with our log files.
You're able to go ahead and
view all of your V-Ray logs
or your Arnold logs
or your NUKE logs.
Everything's been repacked from
a cloud environment to local.
So everything you're
seeing, again,
with the feel of a
local render farm.
There's nothing
cloud that you have
to worry about
pathing differently
or anything like that.
So this first frame
is now downloading.
You can see it's 100% done.
And it's popping right back
into my local output directory.
So I can actually see
the output of that
very quickly without having
to spend a lot of time waiting
for the whole job to finish.
A few other things to mention,
just very briefly here,
that you have all the
standard render manager
controls you have in a job.
You can stop a job.
You can restart a job.
You can pause a
job, cancel a job.
You can add more machines to
it by changing the job options.
Zync's already rendered
this job before,
so it knows how long
the job should take.
And it's giving me
an approximation
of how much of the job is done.
You can already see it's
48% of the way done.
And that'll continue
to populate.
And on a per-task basis, if you
ever want to take a single VM
and add controls to
that, you can click on it
and then you've got all
these tasks controls.
So I can requeue the
task, skip the task,
and so on and so forth.
So having this is
integrated solution
is really, really
important for us.
So you can see these
first few frames are done.
I'm not going to wait for
the whole job to finish.
But again, I've got my EXRs
coming down one at a time.
And that idea of
parallel scalability,
I don't have to have
an artist submitting
a job to a limited farm
and waiting for that job
and waiting for the jobs
queued behind it to finish.
I spin up one VM
per frame, the job
gets done as quickly as
possible, and I'm back
and I'm working with it.
So my EXRs are coming
in, and I essentially
want to move to the next
stage in the pipeline,
to compositing.
So as you can see
here, all those frames
are coming back down locally.
We're also keeping a
copy on cloud storage.
So when I go into NUKE, I
have a background plate here.
This is actually
rendered on Zync.
But I have my police car
that I just finished,
and it's also been
rendered on Zync.
But I have loaded
up the local EXR,
just did a very
quick A over B comp,
a little bit of motion
blur, a little bit of glow.
Save that project,
and I can essentially
just repeat the same process.
So now when I go to
render on Zync here,
the plugin is going to launch.
And you can see, I have
this Upload Only check box.
So this is what you want to
do with live action footage.
You get the plates at
the beginning of a show,
just bring in all your
plates into a dummy comp,
run upload only, submit the job.
But in this case, I know this
CG was just rendered on Zync,
and Zync knows it.
Zync's going to make sure
that all the assets needed
are already there.
In this case, that's the case.
So I can just choose
a 16-core machine.
I'll just use one machine, put
my username and password in,
submit the job, and it's just
essentially a rinse and repeat
process.
So that job is
submitted to Zync.
The NUKE script is going up.
Zync will make sure
all the assets needed
for the render are up there.
But of course, our CG was
already rendered on Zync,
so there's no
unnecessary file I/O.
And essentially,
that's the workflow.
So again, I'm not
going to make you
sit through the
entire render, but I
can go ahead and very quickly
bring up my final output, which
would just come back
to my output directory
as soon as it's done, and
play that back for you.
And there you have it.
So that's the Zync
workflow for you.
Try to make it as integrated as
possible, working within host
applications.
And again, it could
be very exciting today
to hear the other
rendering solutions.
I know Atomic Fiction has
done great work with Conductor
IO, Thinkbox Deadline,
many of you use that,
and the Avere folks as well.
So we're really going for
the gamut of solutions here.
And you're going to
be hearing about all
of them coming up
this afternoon.
So thank you.